[Music]
in fashion police can you imagine the
fashionable oh my god you're not gonna
wear car or corduroy are you gives them
a ticket how to be part of that [ __ ]
with a nice little [ __ ] unicorn pen
and in the pen has like like chicken
feathers on the back yeah I love your
sense of fashion till she says it
awesome that's right nice try Ascot here
we go
submitted by dunk on me Geo well first
of all she'll elbow you in the teeth
before she does that perfect she legit
clothes like me once just to put that
out there
she sits around I thought I play
basketball today great that she got
gloves on hold on a second what sport is
it I dipped it in a in a candy ice
chocolate what is it I like pop rocks
and then she got a like am awesome and
started throwing in Canyon like that
would be nice Dutch police are
confiscating expensive clothes from kids
who look to portal whoa no what's it
hard you do a Dutch accent oh you there
like you stole it - [ __ ] yeah pretty
much there would have been taking all my
clothes man damn
anybody who's wearing like Yeezy [ __ ]
would just get free that's
discriminatory yeah I had discriminated
us police with their wooden shoes is
clogging around the neighborhood looking
for bad guys totaling around the place
we tried yodeling that should [ __ ]
harm
have you heard it well the Japanese do
that that looks like Michael yeah
Michael's everywhere yeah this the
police in the city of Rotterdam in the
Netherlands they're taking this
controversial step to reducing crime
only the ones committing the crimes that
are just stealing from the kids and
they're there making it a point by
making them undress in the street Oh be
someone and they can't provide a
reasonable explanation as to how they
obtained the expensive clothing or an
expensive watch then they will look so
reasonable expect they have to have an
explanation as to how they got the money
my parents gave me money what are your
parents do
my parents are drug dealers there you go
now you're gonna get caught I guess
therefore where are they in there
they're gonna make me strip all my
clothes because there'd be like how
you're gonna have that kind of watch but
still have 12 dollar shorts from Walmart
and a [ __ ] t-shirt that's like over
washed and like faded I'm a billionaire
that's okay I could be like I'm American
oh you guys never make any sense yeah so
how the pretty much gonna judge the face
then yeah if your face looks poor you
have to walk around looking smug as [ __ ]
or it could be like you just have one
yeah but then everything else is like
like hand-me-downs a lot of people are
upset about this because they're saying
that this could just make racial
profiling be even more of a problem why
what are they doing choosing only the
black kids that's a threat a lot of
people are saying like obviously this
will only be targeted towards minorities
because you don't know when I was a poor
little lass me remember the first shoes
my parents ever got me that would not
hand me down as a beat up [ __ ] and I was
the only expensive thing I had because
that's what I are to match which are
closed it wouldn't just because that was
the first time my parents got me really
really nice shoes and I swore that [ __ ]
all the [ __ ] time but didn't match my
upper [ __ ] is that what I've been
started making a profit my parents
decided to get me shoes I wanted that's
time what I'm hoping though is that they
do use common sense and they're not
stupid police because cops do catch
people on profiling without evidence
they pulled up they pulled over a lot of
Asians to deal with Asian crime and in
the process a lot of us got our feelings
hurt but I'm doing because I was selling
drugs but then when they pulled me over
I wasn't at that moment yeah but they're
saying that the police are gonna be on
the lookout for big like Rolex watches
or coochie jackets or really expensive
shoes so they're really see then it's
just as fake right just like oh it's not
it's a knockoff you better show them the
[ __ ] kicks right now with those
oh geez superstar she got on real quick
that clam shell but either way knockoffs
are illegal oh don't take away the
knockoff
well I guess they're trying to reduce
the drug trafficking crimes and youth
gangs cuz apparently it's been an issue
in the city so if they try to catch
these kids I have all these really
expensive clothing like all these
expensive things and they can't provide
a reasonable response as to why they
even have that then they're gonna get
confiscated you're gonna make them
undress in the street that's ambitious
yup was a leader in like social progress
and helping people and [ __ ] like that
but this is just another example of
government stupidity because obviously
like the way to handle this situation is
if you give the poor community a chance
at life like where they can get a decent
job and all that stuff and education and
resources and an equal playing field
then they won't have to sell drugs
people don't wake up and go I wanna
[ __ ] sell drugs they do it because
they don't have many options this is
true I mean that's true
but I guess I've also heard the other
reasons as to why they you do it is
because they just make way more money
and it's easier and it's like fast fast
money that's because they don't know
other options like for example like
people with that come from a middle
class and upper middle class and
everything else like they go oh I could
invest in crypto or I could do a startup
business or whatever it's in their
vocabulary you know what I mean like
they it's it's it's within reach land oh
I'll just open up a restaurant with my
friends you know stuff like that but for
the poor community that's not even a
option it doesn't even exist they don't
even know where to start but they do
know drug dealers and then they go oh
well that's an opportunity I'm gonna
take that that's true you know if you
don't give people the opportunity to
fish it's kind of like Somalian pirates
you know they don't have any other
opportunities so how they gonna feed
themselves they see successful pirates
I'm gonna be a pirate - that's true cuz
my friend who was teaching out in
Mississippi when she asked her kids like
what they wanted to do they're like I
don't know I'll probably just not work
and live off welfare like my parents
I said you gonna say your friend somali
pirates [ __ ] my friend was a Somali
pirate I'm like I gotta meet this guy I
immediately just that's the exam yeah
and like they they don't shoot any
higher like she even was like oh don't
you want to be like this or maybe like
this like don't want to be like a Kenyan
pirates that come on oh I mean I
remember in elementary school all the
people that were like in junior high and
high school and they already had cars
and like lowriders and in like some
bikes yeah and new clothes and stuff
their brothers were like selling drugs
or doing something like that and then so
that's kind of like the first idea of
what success is right but then if you're
from like a upper middle class
neighborhood and you you can see like oh
this so-and-so's dad's a doctor and they
drive this nicey-nicey cars or something
I see cars then your idea of success is
just different it's like oh [ __ ] that's
cool doctors so and so you know has
like eight cars yeah I'll just be a
doctor then when you see like these like
ghetto ass people they flash like their
stack of money and it's really probably
only about $3,000 like this on Instagram
yeah and it's just level one it's like I
mean honestly to like you know people
who they're not all like hundreds or you
know what I mean nah it's like that's
probably like a few grand it's like
that's all that you own like that's it
bro
a few grand is a lot though when you're
like when you don't have nothing
well that's why I'm saying that's what
it's to add to what you're saying they
perspective like their ceilings low
ceiling is very [ __ ] low you know
yeah I don't think I ever noticed what
other people had really like that like I
don't I don't think I ever noticed that
there were any rich kids in my school
that had like you're a perfect example
because you came from a middle to lower
middle-class neighborhood right so
everyone that's in your circle like from
role models to friends and everyone
right their idea of success is maybe
becoming a registered nurse or like
maybe that's too high even for a lot of
people maybe a licensed certified
whatever like a nurse helper
or getting some $12 job doing data entry
right so like if you look at it on a
poverty level if already at a
middle-class level everybody's
aspiration is to be like the doctor's
helper not even the doctor yeah then
these guys their idea of success is
gonna be like of McDonald's employees
right now it does doesn't it maybe
that's a bad idea or like you know
they're just gonna look at the guy
that's like oh rapper
you know maybe drug dealer no that's
very true because I think my biggest
aspiration in life before meeting you
guys was I don't want to be a flight
attendant I want to travel and I just
just for the traveling in the world not
even a pretty dope dream though that is
I remember like I was telling who is
Bobby me like he had asked me when I
first met him like what are your dreams
no like
we travel the world your flight it send
it me me and heels like the dream is too
small like why don't you try going for
like a pilot at least if that's what you
really the pilot is a lot of
responsibility and not everybody can get
that but a flight attendant cute is fun
that's all you need but if it's but if
your goal is to travel the world why not
be ballin as an investor millionaire
woman who just I'm I'm flying in [ __ ]
private jets cuz I'm boss instead of
like let me work for the airline so I
could get a coupon to [ __ ] fly all
over the world you know so I think it it
all depends on where you grow up who
your role models are well what happens
is people who [ __ ] understand that
[ __ ] so all day goes oh look at all
these [ __ ] poor us undisciplined
people that can't get it together
let's criminalize them being poor and
that's what the [ __ ] happened discipline
don't be like me kids there's that other
way to look at it it's like well if in
order to have something good you have to
have something bad and in order to be
rich you have to have the port exactly
because if everyone was middle-class and
rich who's gonna work who's gonna work
the fields and everything I would work
the fields if I got paid the same pay if
everybody else did
David I don't think you were ever
created to work any sort of
labor-intensive job you know
labor-intensive jobs when the field is
made with machinery I don't have to do
[ __ ] you yeah yeah okay so you'd be the
one pressing buttons then I see you
doing that yeah oh so you thought I was
actually lifting bales of hay no I'm the
guy on the tractor where they throw the
hay in the baler so I'm doing this he's
in the tractor with the AC in the fans
blowing on him I just see I'm scheduling
people in no that's not fun I want to be
on the thing with the hay gets tossed in
the back and I'm there like this with
the wheat in my mouth no shoes no shoes
[Music]